now the shot clock at five Sarge picks
up bunny hill he goes over the top bunny
hill
so Phoenix now leads by six
[Applause]
jumpers from bunny hill hold on buddy
gets off to an extremely quick start
right here recognizes the shot clock
foots on them since Miss fourth their
first five shots from three buddy hield
attacks hand and send him to the lodge
what a start in this game for buddy
he'll have been points man nicely done
by buddy comes off just gets right into
the body of Sarge and puts it in that's
calls new-money first foul is eaten off
the mark there got pushed from behind by
Dedmon back comes he'll knock it down
the long to his dams gonna break him
watch out man he took it away from
Washington but rather fake can I beg
your pardon
now buddy in traffic sets up Holmes good
pass
[Applause]
there's one 9987 they're gonna need a
lot more of that Sacramento boy bunny
hill was filed and he'll go to the line
for one more that is sniper level
concentration hits them across the arm
in the head as you see wanna make her
hit buddy hield maybe something starters
on the floor buddy hield and again
boarded the Kings need that James got
very lucky Harry good I don't think he
realized how wide open he was when he
caught the ball there's buddy hield
buddy all the way and put it in the puck
and send them to the line so buddy picks
up right where you left off in basta
puts the ball on the deck splits the
double-team back in his defense it is
just King's ball
great job by Buddy hield right there
Cincinnati's just gregg popovich lore
was the double trouble and a basket way
better right there by buddy here
Belinelli I think you can see all the
[Applause]
buddy decides to take him underneath him
drop off Moth mr. Hill mismatch here the
elites are seized it hangs kicks out
into the corner no good but that's good
basketball but look at who's there
number 24 flying into your picture
one-point game here in the first
and Sacramento takes the lead thanks to
Buddy hield
[Applause]
buddy hield layup good and it's now a
four-point game
numbers two on one buddy the only one
pack and he steals the ball here we go
can the Kings get two points off with
Miami turnover we'll find out yes they
Canton defense right here gets his hand
on the basketball advances it by the
kick 5956
[Applause]
for buddy to get involved and he knows
exactly I mean that is Oh
how about that pass yogi Ferrell to
Buddy hield no fouls to do buddy he
[Applause]
takes the lead 2423
and again they utilize that two-for-one
thanks to the drive by Joseph and
speaking of the drive buddy hield goes
with the left hand and it's a two-point
game and I would like to see an emphasis
called on on the catch and then
relocation of the feet captain his
teammates for easy buckets got to be a
little too sweet
got a hurry here shot clock it to 17
feet away
29:16 Tyus Jones walked in uncontested
two seconds a three-pointer and the
Kings needed that that cuts the lead to
a nine
[Music]
find the theme for the ball and follow
through get this box the time
danger zone right now for the Wizards
down by 14 timeout taken here by Scott
Brooks Jerome Robinson the 23 year old
from Boston College replacing him oh
nice drop-off land tell me something
what time is it
it's Linn time baby